[Music]
cool thank you everyone so yeah I'm
going to talk about one of my favorite
topics which is retention and more
importantly I would say engagement so
I'm able to start as a quick quick pre
fast I'll just use this cool jam board
I'm excited to use it over here so you
know we've all launched mobile games and
there's sort of kind of two states that
you can kind of think of the world that
you know if this is just sort of you
know your revenue Oh God
revenue over time type thing so you see
what you see unfortunately see a lot of
games that they sort of kind of launched
like this where you know there's kind of
a bit of a spike and then they cal fall
down and then the first game update kind
of comes a little spike and then they
sort of you know tail off and then you
see other games you know that are sort
of you know that up and up into the
right and you know the difference
between the two is kind of just a
short-term retention problem these games
that we call shark finning you know
they're sad but it's really a game that
just does not have short-term retention
so when you launch a game like this the
real question is what is your long-term
retention look like and that's the thing
that we're you know we're gonna try to
figure out today so if I just clear this
here so the interesting thing when you
when you think about long-term retention
is you know what does that curve look
like does your curve kind of do this and
continue to grow does it sort of flatten
out or does it sort of kind of die off
at a certain point and when you're
trying to plan a business from a
business point of view this is really
important because unfortunately you know
if you if it's the sort of the ladder
you end up with this what we call kind
of pie plating so you end up launching a
game and then it kind of makes money and
then it kind of dies off and then you
know you hopefully you launch another
game in time so you sort of can kind of
catch it again and so you're in this
sort of horrible sort of mode of where
you're trying to continue to erase
product just to kind of keep you know
your revenue sort of flat which what you
really want is something that looks like
this where you launch one game
and it grows and then the next game
grows on top of it and you get this sort
of stacking and to do this you really
need to understand what long-term
retention looks like so I said most
people sort of fall into this sort of
retention model where it's sort of
cohorted based retention where you sort
of everybody installs on d0
if you come back on the next day after
that your d1 player and so on and so on
and you kind of build like a graph of
this and like I said really what does it
look like because you can you can't
really extrapolate these graphs very
well you don't know where it's gonna
fall off is it gonna level off at some
point you know what is a good number for
day 365 you know who knows right it's
really hard to kind of extract long-term
retention out of this so what most
people end up doing is they sort of
segment right so they fall into this
kind of trap here where they sort of go
well what customers are important so
we're gonna build like a custom sort of
funnel so you start off at the top where
people install the game and then they
might be acquired they might have
finished the tutorial at some point they
come back the next day and they become a
player maybe they put money of the game
and they give you their now customer and
they put more money in the game and you
become a VIP and then you know there's
some sort of a perfect customer that
that you're really looking for the real
problem about this is these are not
service metrics these are retail metrics
so it's very akin to you know old
Sorrell Triple A right you the player is
the person that played the demo the
customer is a person actually bought the
game and then your VIP is sort of your
collector he's a person who's got the
collector edition they got the DLC but
mobile games are not this you know
mobile games are a service right and
service metrics are overtime so it's
really a lot I like using the bar
example so if I was running Cheers
you know I was my primary interest would
not be how many people bought a drink
one night right it really is how many
people come back every single day or
every single time and continue you
repeat customers or your regulars right
so we launched contest of Champions back
in 2014 and it's been you know our
strongest game ever it's gotten
phenomenal retention and what we started
looking at was we try to sort of break
that down and figure out
why this intention was so good so the
first thing we did is we sort of broke
it up by how many metrics sort of broken
up by a number of days of the week that
people play and what we found is the
people that play seven days a week look
nothing like everyone else
so just in an amount of engagement the
number of battles people play a day from
a seven-day player is about two three
times more than a six-day player in fact
the six-day player looks a lot more like
the five-day player then it does a
seven-day player and this also works for
monetization too as well if you if you
sort of normalized it off the one day a
week player as you'll see the seven-day
week player spend you know almost five
times more than your one weekend player
so we said I think we're onto something
here so what we ended up doing is we
sort of looked at lapse rate so here's
four different games that we did they're
all different genres they're all
different levels of success and we said
you know what is the chance that someone
is going to turn the next week after
playing all seven days and what you
realize is basically zero
I think I'm Marvel it's like 0.3% so
it's it's really really stable and it
looks the exact same for all these games
they all look very very similar it's
basically what we call physics for
retention so that gave this concept of
regulars so we say a regular Kabam is
somebody who's complate seven days
consecutive and then that's on a daily
and then on a monthly it's 90% of the
month so 28 days or 31 and so in the
regular based model it's it's much
different and you can look it as a
funnel but I think it's much better off
if you kind of draw this out here
because there's much more like a state
machine than an actual funnel so at the
end of day what you really want to get
to is your sort of your regular
customers
so basically everybody starts off as
being a player they played the game they
install the game now there's kind of two
ways you can become a regular customer
right so the first one is you can put
money in the game and you can be a
customer and then after that you end up
playing seven days consecutive the other
way you can do it is you can kind of go
the other way around so you basically
your regular now because you played
seven days and then you put money into
the game so that's how we kind of
entered the flow now once your regular
customer you're not always a regular
customer so for some reason you missed a
day you kind of go off into this other
pool of being basically non regular
again we call this being weakened but if
you end up playing seven days again you
can come back into the pool there's also
the the the laps people too as well so
for you you end up not playing at all
for 14 days you can kind of fall in this
lapse pool but if you ever come back to
the game you become regular again you
can become a regular customer again so
this is really interesting when you view
it this way because when you think about
your business each one of these groups
need different things right so a player
that comes in and gives you money now
you're trying to figure out how to get
them to play seven days a week
these guys they're obviously playing
seven days a week how do you then
convert them for people that have
weekend you try to build game designs
and game systems that are going to bring
them back seven days a week for people
who have lapsed you're gonna try to
reactivate them to figure out why
they've lapsed and then try to meso turn
it back into customers so it's really a
like an organic state machine and it's
really important that all the pieces fit
together because what you realize when
you start kind of digging into this is
you know you're not in the majority the
people kind of go down this path and
then he was pretty easy to cycle people
around here but if you're trying to grow
business the really the difference
between having more regulars than you
had yesterday is really adding up all
these other little percentages and that
you can get throughout this entire
funnel so what are the power regular so
in admire ville over 90% of the monthly
revenue now is through regulars and
we're still growing them three years
into the game so three years o
year-over-year we've continued to have
our daily number of regular users
continues to rise even three years into
the game they end up having over a 97
percent loyalty rate which basically
means a month over a month they're
continued to coming back there's
actually months that we've had over 100
percent royalty rate which is crazy
we've actually had cohorts that are
really old that you're still continuing
to grow regulars and the beautiful part
of is they have a really stable ARP mark
which is actually average revenue per
monthly active regular customer so sorry
about that but art mark very stable
which is great because this if you're
looking to forecast your business you
have it you have a group of people that
never leave and pay you the same amount
every month that's like the it's the
perfect forecasting tool so when we view
this for a business we really think
about how we can service these regulars
and we think about this regularity lens
throughout an entire business and so
we've applied this kind of throughout
our entire operations so how can
technology help so I'm not going to
stress this any much but you just need
to need a good bi system like data is
the most imperative part of this whole
system you need to have sort of multiple
components of it okay now walk it
through them so the first one that we
really think is super important as we
kept this concept of Kabam of a 360 view
of the player so a lot of game companies
are only sort of viewing their world
from what the player does in the game
and that's not the entire picture right
so you have in-game data you have
marketing data you have data from your
community maybe your forms you have
customer service what you really want to
do is view all that and get all that
into one spot so you can see sort of the
360 view of a player a Kabam so we're
not gonna go to to pin the deck but
bigquery is sort of that Center hub of
our data we put a lot of data into
bigquery on Marvell you're looking
around one-and-a-half petabytes of data
alone on the
it's about two trillion rows we're
ingesting if you know three to four
billion events a day on just one single
game and the cool part is you know we've
done table scans where you get you know
a billion rows per second on a query
performance so it's really quite
impressive then we just hook it up to
tableau
great thing about tableau online it's
sort of no ops as well just like
bigquery you can hook it integrate
straight into bigquery and we can build
on reporting on top of that the last
little piece is is you know this is
obviously that you know the predictive
predictive modeling is is the thing
these days
AI is machine learning this is really
about you have this great huge data set
learn off that train your models and
then start predicting and making
predictions about the game and once you
can do that you can do some just really
neat stuff
so why we're going to start talking
about is sort of the top of the funnel
so people getting into the game how do
you get more regulars into the game so
any game that is successful is gonna end
up doing performance marketing so with
performance marketing you're obviously
buying ads on different channels and
platforms are coming into the game
you're able to do a tribute to them and
then you can calculate sort of your
yields right so if your yields are
really based off of how much money you
think you're gonna get out of this
person versus how much you spent to
acquire them the real jerk about that is
yields are very hard to calculate so
often people get fooled Marvel is a
really interesting example because what
we saw since Marvel is a sort of in some
ways it's a collection game people what
we would see is we'd have actually these
users that would come into the game and
they'd spend like crazy until they got
all the champions that they wanted and
then they'd leave and just sort of like
if you can think of it like a numbers
point of view you could have a guy that
comes in spends a thousand bucks on a
month and leave well that's actually not
your highest LTV user what you much
rather have is someone who spends $100 a
month and does so for four or five years
that's the type of users you want to get
to so if you just sort of you know
optimize all your ad spend based off
sort of like day one to day seven yield
you can often get fooled about actually
who are your best users are and you
actually not often
enough for your for your you a spend so
this kind of brought to this concept
that we have at academic called Auto
Tune so what we end up doing at Kabam is
we have this system call the tomb where
you basically we buy tons of devs ads
and you spend money on them and then
once they get in the game and we've
atribute them we have this machine
learning model that can sort of detect
regularity and it can do it really
efficiently in fact it only takes about
eight hours of actual time and we
actually know if someone's gonna be
regular in three months from that and
then what we do is we take that we feed
it back into the machine we can
calculate return on adspend we can
calculate LTVs based on this thing since
we know the retention we know the art
marks and then we just adjust their
bidding so if we're getting tons of
regulars here we're gonna throw them our
money on here if we get less we're gonna
try less down here and then we can shave
we can optimize all kinds of campaigns
we end up having thousands of campaigns
and different creative running at once
and then we just let auto-tune optimize
it for us and like I was saying it's
really really tight so the this is sort
of a graph of sort of the difference in
the score so we're about 95 90 percent
correct on predicting whether or not
somebody's gonna be regular within eight
hours or not so it's it's a really
really useful model for us and it and it
works out really quite well so the next
part in the whole thing is sort of
strengthening players which is really
turning players into regulars so lots of
books and topics on this but it's really
about habituation right trying to make
people to come back and do something
every day tons of books on this there's
lots of different ways to do that and we
can talk about a few of them so we
believe of Kabam strongly that social
game play is one of the strongest ways
to get people to play with each other a
lot of these games are sort of like from
a neurochemical point of view are all
dopamine type things when you start
adding social you start adding different
types of chemicals difficult anning
social pressure and that's why games
that like world of warcraft and such
have lasted for so long it's because
people come there and it's a social
event and people can still play with
their friends and that's what they want
to do so from a technology
you you know people on the internet
aren't always the best so you know we
start when you start adding chat and
stuff like that it's really important
that you kind of have a good filtering
systems so as positive as a experience
can be it can also be horribly negative
too as well so it's really important
that you try to get that in there you
know adding group chat is great and self
regulating traps likely get Alliance
chats and stuff like that are also
excellent and then bridging the gap if
you can get you know real-time chat
translators in there you can start doing
some really interesting social
interactions where you can actually use
you know territorial enemies that can't
communicate with each other to you know
kind of talk it's really really
interesting oops
and then the next one's really alliances
so alliances at least in our games that
have just been incredibly powerful if
you just take the sort term retention
metrics the second someone gets an
alliances their retention basically
triples so we always try to get people
into alliances finding the right type of
Alliance for people and stuff is a very
hard problem it's very interesting and
you can you need to get some great work
on that the social pressure mechanism is
really strong so if you build events
around cooperation or competitive loops
around getting people to do things
together you can get these great just
engagement boosts the funny thing about
this though is actually they also the
number one indicator of churn prediction
is actually when you get kicked out of
your Alliance so people get kicked up
the Alliance your we are on that right
way to get them into a new liance as
much as possible because that's the
number one predictor of churn in our
game and then the next one was kind of
what we call putting on a show so we
think you know if you build a game that
someone can literally play for 24 hours
a day you will probably never have any
problem to monetizing them you just want
to keep them in the game as long as time
we don't believe a lot of people believe
in this sort of concept of like cork or
blue binging and they can binge too much
and they get fat and then they didn't
want to play the game anymore absolutely
do not believe that have no data to
prove that people come if you give them
gun to play and they play it they will
play it it's really about giving people
stuff to do
so if you kind of look at like what a
week looks like in in the contest of
Champions it's all really about layering
so we have about a hundred events a week
that are planned and it's and they all
sort of feed into each other so you want
to build system that can kind of like
you can stack them so you can do a
couple of these events that give you the
rewards that go to the next event that
go to the next event that work on there
there's different types of events for
different types of people some people
play social events like the a VE a VA
other people who play single events like
PvP and grinding giving all these
opportunities for people to play these
different experiences is really
important and what we've done is we've
done a massive investment of tools so
our back-end called sparks so that we
can basically allow live game designers
to tune the game in such a way that this
is feasible and how we do it is is
largely kind of four main main areas so
the first one is really about targeting
so having really strong targeting
capabilities in your back-end is
extremely important because what you can
do is you obviously do split testing so
you can make these changes and see how
they happen you can end up cohorting
players in two different things because
you know someone who's played the game
for three years where some guy comes in
a different game they're obviously you
need to be cohorted in there you can do
geo targeting our backhand is about 200
dimensions and more actually now than of
targeting that we can add to and then
you can also do action based targeting
so someone does something and that it
changes how they handle the next real
strong thing that we that we really are
quite proud of is this concept of
flexible economy so all these games
frankly are kind of similar they're all
where your money is and all these games
is having a real strong meta game system
and a meta game frankly is really quite
simple at its core it's always you do
something you do an action and you get
something so you're always trading one
resource for another and there's an
action in between so if you make that
generic enough you can make your entire
economy generic in a way that it's just
all you're doing is taking this and
doing something and turn it into that
and if you build tools around that so
that your live ops can actually make new
items and make new economies and
sort of shaped them then you can do some
real powerful things and you can also
measure them too as well so our
abstracted economy ends up building and
basically an operation log for every
single action that has an economic value
to it so you have an OP every single
thing that happens and you can measure
that which allows you to do cool stuff
like this sorry so if you're looking at
like a single currency in the game you
can actually see the flow of currency
and where it happens so you can see in
kind of middle there we saw you know
this currency was kind of you know
getting kind of high so what we'll do is
a lab lob someone maybe make a sink
which might be like a an event to try to
drain that currency and that will give
you a different currency which they can
make another following event to drain it
so you can really kind of move your
economy around in ways that you can kind
of alter player behavior and then the
real port and part about this is you
know anytime you get deep into these
sort of data-driven analytics and data
driven systems you really need a way to
manage it all so in the contest of
Champions there's about two to three
hundred megabytes of metadata that
people are always sort of handling and
managing and you got to build tools
around how you actually you know move
the different pieces across different
environments how you qat these how you
actually sort of merge them in and diff
them and stuff like that and if you
don't do that you know you're probably
liable up for a mess I remember one time
an old Caban before we had some of these
things we had built up gotcha box once
and we didn't have these tools and it
was a gotcha box that opened five
thousand more boxes and it was sort of
inception and it was it was a disaster
cleanup so I can't stress this enough
how well you need to have gets to post
about that stuff so and then the last
one is uh really about long-term
retention how do you retain people for a
long time so it's really all about sort
of knowing when someone's gonna leave
you can pretty much predict that like so
there's some really strong indicators
getting kicked in alliances a huge one
velocity changes of how much they play
or how to engage of their game always
seal yields pretty accurate results and
then you kind of build you automate it
then right so you have we machine
learning models that are running all the
time generating fit scores and whether
or not someone's gonna churn if they end
up gonna churn then we'll start setting
them what we think they need they might
be missing you know maybe they've been
playing in the game forever and they
just you know they haven't got the
character they wanted or they or
you know they're running out of currency
you know we're gonna try to give them a
wind back prize and if they don't come
I'll take it to the next level
Automation that we're gonna send them an
email right and they don't come after
that we'll send a push message if they
still don't come after that we can
actually automatically put him back into
a you a campaign and then try to
reactivate them that way and then we can
use deep-linking tool actually give them
reward through the you a campaign so
having that whole sort of automated
system allows to sort of claw back these
users that may be left because of
whatever reason that maybe they didn't
have something could been seasonality I
mean we got Pokemon goad a few years ago
like everyone else did and they you know
it kind of came back to us afterwards
but we were able to claw back a lot of
people during that during that time and
like I said really works
I think we've we raised with this we
raise our daily revenues by about three
to five percent which is with the just
with the automated churn hardest part
about a lot of these things is trying to
figure out why they left you know
deciding whether or not gonna leave or
now it's pretty easy but it's like why
what do I need to give you to make sure
that you come back and then with
reactive Ignatian campaign often you
know when you're doing lots of UA there
is a certain part you know about a
spending is actually way cheaper to
actually sort of try to reactivate good
users than it is to go get brand new
users so sort of in a conclusion here
really it's all about sort of trying to
avoid the shark fin games that can sort
of grow and have done this holistic
approach and use data to do that can
thrive for a very long time I'm pretty
confident that you know Marvel is gonna
be a decade game at this point like I
said we're going in our fourth year
we're still continuing to grow the
business and grow our number of regulars
and you know integrating the technology
around this really allows you to just
kind of handle the players lifestyle so
and like I said every single piece is
important if you if you don't do all the
pieces you will end up you know kind of
like every day you're like the
difference between being like 99.9% of
the people you had yesterday or 100
point one percent it's just really that
close in a lot of cases and just closing
a loop on everything is as is the way
so thank you really appreciate we get
another round of applause for Jeff
[Applause]